Hình Anh bởi tưởng hồi lúc sức trái từng hâm chuyển trong mặt trên mặt sở hội.
Nơi là anh Giang, rồi ai cạo ra.
Con video sả này, tổng thông ủ khai nè bố lưu đi味 trên lần sĩ đánh kêu hỏi
bình lính hạ bố ký đồng hằng khi người xem trên tổn thị dời hoang mang trong vải phút.
Ai biết được, liệu có người tín rất là sự thật.
Bởi tổng cộm mến phí và ký thuật ngày càng tình vì, ai ai có thể cạo ra phân bà,
bình anh. Video đi fact thậm chí là giả xả giậm nói chỉ trong vải phút.
Và khá cối báo Chí, nơi một thông tin cho tiên sống cần giác mình tẩm thật.
Thì thấy giới mạng sáo hội không trở ai xác mình kẻ.
Thông tin giả này chở thành những qua bông điện hướng có sức công phá dừa lật.
Ch Share mối kình đó, nhà báo bố phản nình geba kiến anh chở thành người dài đó thông tin
và trả lại cho công chữ của bản tin chung thực nhất.
Trong thời là ầy ai, kạn người tốt lần kẻ sấu để có thể sử dụng con người.
Nhưng người làm báo chúng ta với sứ mặt bảo vệ sự thật, phải luôn trọt lữ về phía ai sáng và kinh định không để làm vấn đò bị soá mơ.
Phong chỉ là những cho đồ Wi-M, ai ai còn bị bố khi hoa để gây chiế giãi xe ông thu hợp.
Nhưng người ngày xa lại về cậm đồng trụ tập tôn giá ông được làm chuyển có chủ đích.
Tất hiện thấp ra điều traa một chiếc dịch tục tiên giả trên phê xe bút, nhằm kích đặc thu hợp với người palestin và cô cũng chúng nghĩa bài giọt thái.
Điều quyết sức là mọi người nhẹn, điều được tạo ra bởi ai ai.
Chúng của trên này người đọt không vô cán, khi mỗi cái sè kíu xuy nghĩ có thể tiếp t害 cho một chiến sịch giả mạo quy mô lớn, khi đọt báo gần thêm sự trọt lọt và kịp chuyến.
Chúng khi các niệng tảng chuyên báo tôn tiên chưa quả lý hiệu qua, thì ai sẽ giải quyết sự lộu sộ này.
Câu trả lời là báo chiếc, nhưng không phải báo chi hợi hợp chạp theo lửa vưu, mà là báo chiếc có chức nhận giảm đối đồng chúng của trên căng có này.
Dữa thì giới thật giả lạc lột, nhà báo lần người của cùng đứng dưới lạnh sánh gó và chỉ cần họ còn sử dực lượng hề thì công chúng vẫn còn hi vào để nhận biết đô lạnh sáng của sự thật.